Responsible computing is understood
as developing quantum computing
with an awareness of its power
and potential impacts when we say responsible
we need developing and using technology
based on pre defined principles to help us prevent
and mitigate potential harms
while promoting solutions that are proactively
inclusive and accountable at ibm
we've been driven by a sense of responsibility
to society for decades today we call ourselves a catalyst
that makes the world work better that means we
have the responsibility to consider the implications of
the technologies we build and help put to use
as we develop this new technology
the decisions we make today will influence the future
and these decisions
have the potential to have a huge impact on society
for example you may have to decide whether to pursue an application
that helps just a few stakeholders or
one that might solve a societal problem
we hope that you as a client will be able to think
about responsible development of quantum computing to
thinking responsibly can help your business established trust
with investors and consumers
while also building a reputation of integrity
and admiration with your employees
and customers on the flip side
it can help protect you from bad press fines
and penalties in this video
we will introduce important responsibility considerations
to discuss with their team
while you explore corner computing
and its applications when it comes to corn computing
thinking in acting responsibly
means following a set of principles
and values to guide your development
and deployment of technology
for example this means being transparent
about both the limitations and capabilities
of quantum computing today we have language
and our contracts that requires ibm quantum clients
to use our systems responsibly
and that they not use our systems
for nefarious or illegal purposes
we call these are responsible use
and acceptable use clauses
this language is already influencing how our clients think
about developing quantum
for their use cases we can
also help influence the direction of quantum computing
by deciding which applications we pursue
for development and acceleration
in order to protect against potential irresponsible uses
of our technology we also have developed robust ibm quantum
safe technology as you are thinking about how
and for what to use one computing
make sure you speak realistically about your expectations
for con computing and the timelines
in which you hope to incorporate quantum
do not present quant computing
as mysterious rather try to explain it realistically
and as computing hardware
that follows the rules of quantum physics
make sure your use case for quantum computing
is proactively inclusive
and is considering all potential stakeholders
to determine the extent
of any negative societal impacts
make sure you have to find clear principles
and values for your use case exploration
and development thank you
for watching we hope that
as you bring useful crime computing to the world
you'll also think about how you can do this responsibly.
The the